[Music]
okay new business
i have a brilliant idea
stony brook summer camp for seniors no
a day camp for our clients they'll give
us a new service to offer it'll be a
total gold mine
and most important it's a way for us to
stay together the whole summer
is this not the most brilliant idea yet
[Music]
one of those boys was ever seen again
the only clue to what happened was a
muddy handprint
on the side of the tent they say the
muddy hand is still out there
looking for more wilderness explorers
and revenge
[Music]
i don't buy it how can a hand move all
by
okay if itself about to die i'm sorry i
didn't mean any of that stuff i said i
love all of you i love all of you
awesome nerds and i love being about i'm
just so stressed out
oh my gosh jessica and ashley i don't
actually know which one of you is which
i'm jessica don't worry we're going to
get you down focus up get information we
can do this
come on let's focus what work together
as a team
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Music]
do you have a favorite subject
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
we just quit now not until we sing
[Music]
kumbaya
[Music]
you